alors on a commencé des missions vous
parlant de ces resserrements sur le plan
des mesures sanitaires en ontario face à
la menace croissante des variants parmi
ces mesures il ya l'interdiction des
voyages interprovinciaux centre en
vigueur à minuit dans la nuit du 18 au
19 avril donc les gens qui doivent
traverser les frontières entre l'ontario
et le manitoba entre l'ontario et le
québec pour aller travailler pour des
soins médicaux ou pour le transport de
marchandises seront autorisés de même
que les autochtones et qui ont des
droits en vertu des traités on va voir
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on pense de
tout seul maire de gatineau qui
directement concerné par sa maxime
pedneaud-jobin bonsoir monsieur ben bon
soir alors dites nous votre réaction
initiale en voyant ça vous comprenez
l'urgence d'agir
mais parlons des conséquences pour vous
et votre beaucoup comme étant d'abord
l'urgence est clair puis moi je pense
que les gens vont comprendre ce qui se
passe en ontario on veut pas que ça se
passe partout et les dernières données
font un font peur en fait les
conséquences chez nous et on l'a vécue
au printemps c'était le québec avait mis
le même type de barrages sur les ponts
notamment le de notre côté de la rivière
dans la mesure où les policiers
utilisent leur jugement et moi je leur
fais confiance pour les exceptions parce
que on a au moins 400 en ontario qui
travaillent dans nos hôpitaux ou chez
nous c'est encore peser beaucoup plus
que ça des gatinois qui travaillent à
ottawa notamment dans les hôpitaux
donc il faut que les gens puissent
traverser aller travailler ce sont des
travailleurs est essentielle
moi j'ai parlé au maire watson ya
quelques minutes pour l'assurer de notre
collaboration on peut aussi partager de
l'expérience on a tous vécu au printemps
la lasser ses services de police qui
vont qui vont l'appliquer ou la police
ontarienne jeu pas sûr mais on est prêt
à partager notre expertise parce qu'on a
vu on a joué à peu près tout les cas de
figure au printemps oui et on a vu tous
les cas de figure dans l'opinion des
gens à gatineau dans un micro trottoir
qu'on a fait tout à l'heure il n'en
présentait l'émission est aussi on a
parlé un médecin spécialiste nous dit
tout ça est mise en place
peut-être davantage pour protéger les
provinces voisines que l'ontario elle
même
évidemment quand on pense aux variants
est ce que ces genres de mesures qui
vous rassure
qui va qui vous rassurent quant à la
propagation de ces variants sur votre
territoire vous mais moi j'ai pas
d'expertisé en santé publique serait que
j'hésite à porter un jugement sur la
mesure elle même ce que je sais c'est
qu'on est capable de le faire on le fait
d'un côté de la rivière
le principe que je défends depuis
monsieur martin et moi on dit exactement
les mêmes mots le sait être un bon
voisin aujourd'hui le cepos voisine
c'est pas les bois ans est resté chacun
chacun chez soi soit pour moi c'est le
principe général
après c'est la mécanique elle même qui
est l'outil que le gouvernement prend en
ontario ils prennent cet outil là au
québec celle c'est aussi couvre-feu si
on isole chacune des mesures chacune des
mesures peut être critiqué mais
globalement ce conseil c'est que ça va
vraiment pas bien et qu'on doit qu'on
doit agir des hôpitaux haute en ontario
que de notre côté de la rivière sont
fragiles
les variants amène des gens qui sont
plus jeunes gens à l'hôpital plus
longtemps donc c'est moi je pense la
population va comprendre notamment
voyant les les données lucky qui
s'améliorent pour eux surtout pas
notariaux même si elle se prolonge à
long terme
ce genre de mesure la belle est ce qu'on
comprend c'est que c'est jusqu'au 21
grain je crois donc c'est quand même une
longue période mais c'est pas non plus
cinq ans alors c'est là que dans les
huit prochaines semaines l'immense
majorité des québécois vont avoir été
vacciné et c'est ça qui est en quelque
sorte la lumière au bout du tunnel
pour moi c'est pour serrer les coudes
faut endurer il faut être courageux
jusqu'à jusqu'à ce moment là pour se
rendre au mois de juin avec le moins de
souffrance humaine possible mais un
vaste effort collectif qui requit haute
au sein des provinces et entre les
provinces merci beaucoup monsieur
pedneault jobin au revoir merci beaucoup
bonne soirée sur et enchaînant tout de
suite avec madeleine et sébastien
bonsoir chers collègues
alors comment sont évidents par la
situation en ontario c'est l'épicentre
de la pandémie au pays et tous les
regards étaient rivés sur ce qu'elle a
annoncé sur la conférence de presse de
monsieur x d'ailleurs qui a pris un peu
de retard
on sentait bien qu'il y avait des défis
la tâche et étant donné
tous les fronts qui sont ouverts en ce
moment sur le plan sanitaire en ontario
avec un manque de ressources est criant
bref on écoute monsieur fort pendant
jase après
alors voilà le temps était très grave
madeleine mais on entendait tout à
l'heure un spécialiste en infectiologie
qui en 15 avec nous les traits tirés
fatigué on peut plus dire écoutez oui
c'est bien ça peut aider mais serait
peut être plus dans une large mesure le
prolongement de ce qu'on a déjà avec
quelques exceptions près est-ce qu'ils
ont ça qu'il ya quelque chose de plus
auraient pu être fait et ça n'a pas été
fait peut-être pour des raisons
politiques je ne sais trop vous disiez
alexis tous les regards étaient tournés
vers d'oxford
moi j'avais l'impression que d'autres
fortis et regarder ailleurs
regardez donc ce qui se fait au québec
regarder ce qui se fait au manitoba on
va fermer les frontières même si
finalement la transmission est moins
grande dans ces deux provinces là il dit
aussi regarder vers lé du côté du
gouvernement fédéral qui nous donne pas
assez de vaccins
donc dans une déclaration écrite le
gouvernement ford a dit si on avait
trois cent mille doses par jour là on a
on réussir et à la gagner cette bataille
variant contre vaccin mais trois cent
mille doses par jour ça si on fait le
calcul mais au prorata de la population
ça veut dire qu'il faudrait que le
gouvernement fédéral obtiennent par
semaine plus de 5,5 millions de doses
on est loin du compte donc c'est comme
si donc faut dire si on avait une
baguette magique mon dieu que ça irait
mieux
on ne l'a pas cette bague hachimette
baguette magique là est donc forte
semblait vouloir porter le blâme sur
d'autres que lui même si en ce moment
c'est lui qui dans le pétrin avec la
contamination dans sa province ben voilà
pour la baguette magique mais dans son
coffre à outils comme d'autres chefs de
gouvernement il y aussi d'autres options
comme le couvre feu comme le confinement
mais il ne franchit pas se passer
bastien dont il dit quand même que ces
policiers vont pouvoir donner des
amendes aux gens qui respectent pas les
restrictions sanitaires vous posiez la
question est-ce que ça va assez loin on
peut en effet se demander si ça va assez
loin il ya des des chaînes d d d
industrie qui sont pas touchés où il ya
beaucoup de proximité entre les
travailleurs qui travaillent sur des
chaînes qui a vient dans la maison par
la suite peut contaminer les gens qui
sont dans leur maison avec l'effet
exponentielle que ça peut avoir par là
dessus il ya certaines personnes qui se
disent que peut-être que ces chaînes
d'approvisionnement ou si ses juges
aurait dû être fermées je ferai dit ben
là attention parce que la chaîne
d'approvisionnement pourraient être
mises en danger si on ferme ce genre d'
usine est question aussi qu'on peut se
poser c'est est-ce que ça ça aurait pas
dû être fait avant parce que ça fait
deux trois semaines qu'on voit la courbe
monte à notariaux concis que c'est la
troisième vague qu'on sait que c'est les
variants qu'on sait que les variants
c'est de façon exponentielle que ça se
propage alors si on compare ici avec le
québec par énorme monsieur legault si on
compare à contrario a fait des espèces
de frappes préventives en disant on
adopte certaines mesures avant que ça
parte en vrille comme si en train de
partir en ontario alors deux approches
avec deux résultats pour l'instant
différents puis on va se garder une
petite gêne parce que ça peut changer
extrêmement rapidement nous avons
comparé les deux provinces du haut
calibre
les mesures certaines préventive de
françois legault ambarès comme des bons
coups pour l'instant est aussi cet appel
aussi à l'aide selon le comm ca envers
les autres provinces certaines d'entre
elles qui ont répondu assez rapidement
non mais un nom assez ferme pour
l'octroi ou l'envoi plutôt de personnel
ou de vaccins et madeleine là dessus
c'est assez singulier il y avait
l'association médicale canadienne qui
avait parti le bal ce matin en publiant
une lettre le disant faudrait revoir la
façon de partager les ressources
partagées les ressources humaines mais
partagée aussi l'approvisionnement en
vaccins pour changer la formule pour ne
plus y aller au prorata de la population
pour finalement envoyé des doses là où
les points sont les plus chauds pour
sauver des vies donc c'est une approche
et il ya la nouvelle écosse entre autres
qui a dit bien d'autres outils et tout à
l'heure sébastien parler par exemple du
couvre-feu
d'autres façons de fonctionner la
nouvelle écosse a dit 'nous on a adopté
des mesures tôt dans la pandémie on
s'attend à ce que les autres provinces
fasse pareil moi ça me donne l
impression un peu de la cigale et de la
fourmi
vous savez vous avez danser tout l'été
vous avez chanté tout l'été maintenant
danser c'est parce que le premier
ministre de nouvelle écosse a dit mais
je trouvais qu'il y avait un petit ton
de reproche dans la voix en disant nous
on a adopté des mesures
laissez nous maintenant nous vaccin
parce qu'on sait jamais où peuvent être
les prochaines éclosion donc des
provinces veulent évidemment protéger
leurs populations
mais c'est un débat
qui très très délicat parce qu'on parle
quand même de visuels non mais chaque
province veut protéger sa population et
on peut le comprendre
ouaip et le principe c'est de diviser
les vaccins au prorata de la population
opus est un principe que tout le monde
accepte juste un truc doit pas fermer la
porte à moins que je me trompe madeleine
dans son point presse à la possibilité
de réviser cette façon de faire
il n'a pas dit qu'il voulait la réviser
non plus mais est ce que en bout de
ligne il va devoir envoyer plus de
vaccins en ontario parce que c'est
l'épicentre de l'épidémie de la pandémie
au pays
c'est peut-être à ce à quoi il va devoir
arriver mais pour faire ça sans se
mettre les premiers ministres dont
l'histoire des compétences
oui ça va être très difficile d'autant
que la région du premier ministre de la
nouvelle écosse traduisent ce qui
pourrait s'en tenir comme réaction des
autres premier ministre ait eu d'abus
l'atlantique pour haïti au québec on
pourrait dire on a pris des mesures
préventives en atlantique on pourrait
dire on a eu le but l'atlantique on
s'est protégé on a préservé notre
territoire
l'ontario l'a pas fait sans dire
débrouillez avec votre robe de bruit
vous avec vos troupes parce que personne
ne dira jamais ça les gens sont tous
dans la même situation il veut les
vaccins des vaccins c'est la lueur
d'espoir pour sortir de cette crise là
et je suis pas sûr qu'ils vont vouloir
partager
on passe après appel à la solidarité
pancanadienne ce serait ce serait un
test à propos de justin trudeau moi
l'impression qu'ils me donnaient durant
le point de presse et si les provinces
sont d'accord on va être d'accord mais
arrangez vous entre vous les provinces
donc il voulait pas porter l'odieux
justement de commencer à déshabiller
paul pour habiller pierre
les provinces disent on veut aider si
possible notamment les provinces
atlantiques on pourrait envoyer par
exemple du personnel la logistique du
matériel mais touchez pas à nos vaccins
c'était pas mal l'impression que ça me
donnait entre autres de la nouvelle
écosse mais aussi de
terre-neuve-et-labrador vraiment là est
ce que tout le monde l'ait vu les
vaccins plombier de formation est
clairement exaspéré l'aïd y érigeant des
vaccins si on avait commencé au mois de
février comme tout le monde recevait
d'aidé à travers le monde recevait des
vaccins au mois de février bon d'être
qui généralise un peu on n'en serait pas
là il l'a dit pendant sa conférence de
presse
mais c'est la même situation dans toutes
les provinces tout le monde le veut les
vaccins pourront se sortir de cette
fille est là on a commencé à vacciner
tous
au royaume uni par exemple y avait aussi
des mesures très très strictes quant au
déplacement de la population et tout le
reste
quelques minutes qui nous reste est
important de le faire on va aller
consacrée au budget fédéral qui s'en
vient lundi prochain j'espère vous allez
bien vous reposer en fin de semaine
parce que beaucoup de choses à dire mais
déjà comme on peut déjà mettre la table
à ce stade-ci là dessus ça va être
fortement marqué par la pandémie et la
crise sanitaire madeleine
oui c'est un budget qu'on pourrait
peut-être appelées hybrides leur
fortement marqué par la pandémie
qu est ce qu il reste combien ça nous a
coûté jusqu'à maintenant d'abord on
devrait avoir une colonne de chiffres là
dessus qu'est ce qui reste à faire pour
lutter contre la pandémie qui est encore
en cours la troisième vague et comment
relancer l'économie par la suite
donc on est dans un pied dans la
pandémie qu'un pied qui veut en sortir
aussi de cette pandémie la et de la
crise économique et doit y avoir un plan
de relance qui devrait se chiffrer entre
70 et 100 milliards de dollars sur trois
ans et alexis on me disait dans les
bonnes hanning un budget qui présente 25
milliards de dollars de nouvelles
dépenses sur 50
une bonne année imaginez on parle de 70
à 100 milliards de dollars sur trois ans
donc l'ampleur est tout autre est ce
qu'on me disait c'est que ça va
peut-être permettre à justin trudeau
d'imprimer sa vision sur ce à quoi
pourrait ressembler l'économie de demain
évidemment la relance à ce propos juste
pour imaginer une nouvelle économie
à quoi pourrait ressembler le canada en
2015 faut aussi s'occuper des secteurs
de l'économie qui ont été
particulièrement touchés comme le
tourisme comme les transports comme la
culture mais aussi faux pauvres aussi
c'est je pense que le gouvernement veut
saisir cette occasion là pour essayer de
d'être concurrentiel avec les autres
j'économise mondiale qui investissent
aussi pour relancer leur économie a pris
puis va voir la pression aussi pour
prolonger les mesures dead sais c'est
pas parce que au mois de juin juillet
peut-être qu'à peu près tous les
canadiens vont avoir reçu une dose du
vaccin que
des problèmes économiques vont pas seul
sans aller de sitôt pilonnent les gars
il va encore y avoir besoin de ces
programmes des depuis ses problèmes des
deuils coûte cher donc il va avoir de la
pression pour continuer à investir et
très bien alors il ya longtemps qu'on ne
peut présenter un budget fédéral et on
le ferait deux ans quand même un peu
plus de 2 cela n'a pas eu depuis la
dernière élection
et si le premier budget de chris
sheridan pour la première femme ministre
des finances sur la scène fédérale
et donc ça je suis certaine que le
gouvernement fédéral va vouloir le
rappelait aussi parce que c'est un
gouvernement qui se dit féministe
attendez vous à ce qu'il y ait de
l'argent pour un programme national de
garderies de d'apprentissage préscolaire
là ça que chaque fruit l'asnl a déjà
télégraphié assez clairement je vous
dirais s'il ne le fait pas là elle a
envoyé des drôles de signaux parce que
elle va voir à diriger tout le monde
dans la mauvaise direction
bien de voir ça tous les groupes de
pression aussi qui sont à l'affût qui
attend de voir ce que représentait mme
adam freeland c'est donc ce lundi
prochain émission spéciale patrice roy
sera là évidemment en compagnie de vous
sébastien et madeleine que je remercie
et vous souhaite un bon week end
au revoir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit